this is a production of cornell
university
thanks for the introduction chris i also
grew up in ithaca
and was a research assistant at cornell
back in the summer of 2008
so it's been a real pleasure to be back
here again even if just over zoom
after my time at cornell i went off to
grad school at the university of
michigan as chris said
and while i was there i studied range
expansion dynamics of plants
in response to climate change
specifically i focused on biotic
interactions between
range expanding plants and herbivores
and pathogens
the core of my work was a series of
transplant experiments across a
latitudinal gradient
and in these experiments i quantified
how biotic and
abiotic processes affected plant growth
and survival
data from these field experiments gave
me a chance to study how these processes
varied across
spatial scales ranging from meters to
hundreds of kilometers
and to quantify how these processes
affected plant populations
i also investigated the effects of
various global change drivers on plant
populations using meta-analysis
ultimately this work was motivated by
the desire to both
understand how climate change will
affect these forests
and the hope that this knowledge would
inform management practices
these are my research themes creating
models of ecological processes for
individual plants
scaling to populations and landscapes
and using this information to inform
management
however it's hard to manage processes
that are occurring on time scales of
centuries
and i decided i wanted to work on a
plant ecology topic
that had more immediate relevance to
people's lives
so after my phd i began to apply these
same research themes to a new topic
airborne pollen in my talk today
i'm going to start by covering the
current state of affairs in airborne
pollen
and then move on to describe the
spacio-temporal models of airborne
pollen that i've created
by quantifying pollen production plant
location
and flowering phenology through the talk
i'm going to show you how i've applied
these same methods
to urban trees and ragweed plants in
detroit
to juniper trees in texas and then i'm
going to tell you a little bit
about my future research plans of
applying similar methods
to trees at continental scales
almost all gymnosperms and at least 10
percent of angiosperms are wind
pollinated
in temperate regions like ithaca this
includes most
trees and lots of important crops too
for these plants understanding airborne
pollen is critical for understanding
gene flow
and this is relevant to research that's
being done now at sips
for example pollination is required for
hemp crops that are being grown for
grain
whereas airborne pollen can interfere
with hemp being grown for cbd
another relevant agricultural issue is
the spread of herbicide resistance genes
across
landscapes similarly
understanding airborne pollen is
important for paleo ecologists that
reconstruct
plant communities using pollen grains
and sediment cores
or fossils pollen also
directly affects human health by
triggering allergic reactions
and an understanding of airborne pollen
is important in all of these examples
and to many examples that i haven't
listed
over the next few days i'm looking
forward to talking with many of you
about this topic and how my research
themes
might apply to your study systems too
that being said for most of today i'm
going to focus on airborne pollen
through the lens of allergies and human
health
pollen allergies are becoming
increasingly common around the world
and rising carbon dioxide concentrations
also cause plants to produce more pollen
and pollen that is more allergenic
and even though pollen allergies are
sometimes dismissed as just a nuisance
they make life miserable for millions of
americans and people around the world
they also have big societal consequences
including millions have lost
school and work days every year and can
also trigger potentially fatal asthma
attacks
most of what we know about airborne
pollen comes from pollen monitoring
stations
there are about 80 of these stations in
the united states which are run through
the national allergy bureau network
and each of these stations takes
integrated daily measurements
here's a map of these monitoring
stations
if we zoom into the northeast you can
see that the nearest station to ithaca
is in rochester about 75 miles away
the current paradigm in this field is to
just use data from the nearest
monitoring station
in other words it is standard practice
to assume that pollen concentrations in
ithaca
are the same as they are on one roof in
rochester
in fact when you see pollen
concentrations reported in the media
what you're usually getting is
yesterday's measurements
likely from tens of miles away from you
also while the forecasting methods that
are used by companies
are usually proprietary one of the
poorly kept secrets is that a lot of
these forecasts from
leading websites are actually based off
of allergy medication
sales which is not always the best proxy
for
airborne pollen concentrations so
even in the best case these predictions
of airborne pollen generally assume that
pollen is homogeneous within regions
surprisingly there's very little data on
how pollen concentrations
vary within regions one potential
explanation for why we don't know more
is that most plant ecologists don't know
much about allergies
and most allergists don't know much
about plants so i think this is kind of
fallen into gaps between fields a little
bit
however there's another really big
reason why we don't know more
and that is the the methods that are
used for sampling pollen
and traditionally two types of samplers
have been used the roto-rod and the
burkhart sampler
these samplers were designed about 70
years ago and haven't changed much since
then
they're bulky they need to be plugged
into ac
power and they also aren't cheap
which makes it difficult to conduct
these large
simultaneous measurement campaigns that
we need
to figure out how pollen varies
over relatively small spatial scales
one of my contributions here was making
an updated design of one of these pollen
sampler types myself
and i was lucky enough to get some help
from a few
engineering grad students on this and i
ended up soldering together a fleet of
these samplers
the designs for them are currently in
prep for submission to an open source
hardware journal
with these samplers i was able to
empirically test whether this large
assumption of pollen being homogeneous
within a region was true
next i'm going to show you some results
on that
this is a map of detroit the study area
for my first postdoc
and this map shows simultaneously
collected oak pollen measurements across
detroit the color of each of these
circles
indicates airborne pollen on a
particular day
so this is just one day as an example
and
i'd like to note that the color scale
here is logarithmic
and the take home message from this is
that pollen concentrations
do vary dramatically over relatively
short
distances
it also shows why using a single station
as a proxy for an entire region
doesn't work all that well in fact
measurements from that pollen station
shown in the upper right hand corner of
this map
they only explain about six percent of
the variation in oak pollen across the
area
across the season so uh and i should
also point out that other taxa had
similar results and concentrations
on a particular day often varied by
two or three orders of magnitude across
the city
to me this means that we've been making
bad assumptions about exposure to
airborne pollen
because we haven't been thinking about
it spatially
i think it's time for a paradigm shift
and our understanding of airborne pollen
in my talk today i'm going to show you
the benefits of transitioning from
a phenomenological monitoring network to
a spatial modeling approach that
includes the underlying ecological
and biological processes i think this
has the potential to
revolutionize our understanding of
allergenic pollen exposure
so in the next section of my talk i'm
going to walk you through my approach to
modeling airborne pollen
which requires answering these questions
first how much pollen does a single
plant produce
second where are the plants that are
releasing pollen
and third when are these plants
flowering
and releasing pollen now each of these
are basic research
questions on their own but the
combination of them leads to
applied solutions to real world problems
and in fact even though this is research
on plants
the health implications here are strong
enough that it was competitive for nih
funding
which supported my postdoc at u of m
so let's dive into pollen production my
goal was to be able to
estimate an individual tree's pollen
production as a function of its size
but no such equations had been developed
for north american tree species
and the equations that had been
developed for trees elsewhere
generally used pretty coarse methods
i set about creating equations for
several tree species
but for most of my talk today i'm going
to show you examples from oak trees
because they are common and produce lots
of allergenic pollen
at this point i'd also like to
acknowledge victoria bankowski who was
an
undergraduate student who worked with me
for two years on a couple of projects
including this one
here's an example of how i estimated
pollen production
first i selected trees of a range of
sizes
and then i borrowed a trick from my days
of assessing understory light
availability
and took hemispherical photos of each
tree's canopy
these photos made it easy for me to
systematically
and quantitatively estimate the number
of flower clusters per tree
i then took branch samples and counted
the number of
catkins per cluster and then counted the
number of anthers per catkin
and finally counted the number of pollen
grains per anther
i then multiplied all of these together
to estimate a tree's pollen production
so the question is how well can we
predict
pollen production based on a tree's size
on the x-axis here is a tree's canopy
area
and on the y-axis is the number of
pollen grains produced
in millions so let's take a look at the
results
the dots here are individual trees and
the lines are regressions
the mean is in blue and the variation
which is based on bootstrapping
is in gray so for red oak trees
larger trees produced more pollen and
they did so
in a predictable fashion
this held true for the other species in
the study too
and it turns out that tree size is
a very good predictor of pollen
production
that being said i want to take a moment
to focus in on something here i've
i have uh pollen production in the
millions but
it's kind of hard to get a good gut
sense of what a hundred million pollen
grains means
so i want to put those numbers in some
context
the largest white mulberry tree that i
measured had about 125 million anthers
here's an animation of a single white
mulberry anther releasing pollen
that single anther has about 50 000
pollen grains in it
but only it only takes as few as 15
pollen grains
per cubic meter of air for the most
sensitized people to have an allergic
reaction
so imagine being allergic to white
mulberry
and having hundreds of these trees in
your city
the next step in developing a model of
airborne pollen was to figure out where
each of these trees were now my study
area
was the city of detroit which is big and
at 360 square kilometers
there's no way to measure all of these
trees by hand
luckily we're living at a time when vast
amounts of new remote sensing data
are becoming available as are processing
techniques to manage it
and these can be applied to tasks like
tree
identification of these new data sources
is a company called near map which takes
high resolution
aerial images of most urban areas in the
us
a few times a year and this data set had
never been used for
tree identification i combined it
the the multi-temporal aerial images
from your map
with a few other data sets including
lidar and a street tree database
and used that to identify trees in
detroit
i'm going to show you a brief overview
of how i did this analysis
but if you have questions about the
details i'd be happy to discuss it more
in the question and answer session after
the talk
okay so here's an aerial image of one
spot in detroit
you can see trees houses a golf course
and now let's overlay that lidar data on
top of this
lidar provides information about the
three-dimensional structure
of things and here the the lighter
colors
the white corresponds to taller objects
with this information about the height
of each object
we can then use segmentation algorithms
to segment segment these into canopies
of individual trees or at least large
piece
pieces of a tree and that's shown by
these yellow polygons here
i then extracted various indices from
the aerial imagery
and the lidar and used that to classify
the trees
the color of each polygon here
corresponds to the predicted taxon of
that tree canopy polygon
this worked out great for several facts
but others i couldn't tease apart as
well
but even with these limitations these
predictions of
individual tree identity are incredibly
useful
i'd also like to note that we're on the
cusp of tree identification with remote
sensing
being operational and over the next few
years these data sets are going to
become
more and more widespread and
accessible now i'd like to draw your
attention to these green polygons which
are oak trees
and here's where it gets really exciting
because we know the area of each of
these tree canopy polygons
we can plug in those allometric
equations of pollen production
to predict how much pollen each of these
trees
is going to produce
and here's estimated pollen production
for each oak tree in this frame
now because this is done with remote
sensing data though
we can scale this up so let's zoom out
to the whole neighborhood here
and this is the the university district
in detroit
it's an area with a lot of oak trees now
let's
zoom out even more to the whole city
the square on this slide is where the
previous slide
left off and here we are a map of oak
pollen production
for detroit based on pollen production
by
individual trees this is really cool and
you can just see the differences in
neighborhoods
between oak pollen production
but the next big question is whether
nearby pollen production predicts
airborne pollen
after all people have long assumed that
because pollen can blow long distances
that it usually does let's take a look
the x-axis of this figure is predicted
pollen production
around a sampling site and the y-axis is
the average concentration of airborne
pollen during the springtime
based on repeated sampling
so to answer the question of whether
there's more airborne
pollen near source plants the answer is
yes
there's definitely a strong relationship
here
this is an exciting finding because it
provides
very strong evidence that local plants
are driving airborne pollen
concentrations
in other words this shows that if you
live in a neighborhood with more
oak trees you're likely going to be
exposed to much more
oak pollen i'd also suggest that if
you're allergic to oak trees you
shouldn't be planting one in your front
yard
now this is common sense but we haven't
had a scientific
basis to justify that before and
and so this finding is really relevant
for large landowners like municipal
governments
and points to the possibility of being
able to intentionally create
lower allergen landscapes
so my major conclusion here is that
we should be including allergenic pollen
production as
one criterion in our tree selection
decisions
because the choices that we're making
about what trees we plant
it affects pollen exposure for the
people that live nearby
now one concern is that this finding
could be interpreted
as an argument for having fewer trees in
cities
i have two responses to this first one
of the best management options
is to just plant different trees and
specifically
uh we could plant cultivars that produce
less pollen
the other response that i have is that
allergenic pollen
it's just one of the many ways in which
we're interacting with trees
and in almost all circumstances the
ecosystem services provided by
trees will dramatically outweigh the
ecosystem
disservices of allergenic pollen
i'd also like to point out that the same
framework that i'm using
understanding processes for individual
plants scaling them
up and using that information to inform
management we can
also apply this to some of those
ecosystem services that these trees are
providing
so i'm going to take you on a brief
detour and show you shade as an example
of this
so take this tree here in austin
and then look at it from above outlined
in blue
to understand the shade provided by this
tree we can create a mechanistic model
that takes into account the height of
that tree
and the angle of the sun on any
particular day of the year
here's an animation of mottled shade
throughout the day
you can see the trajectory of the sun
across the sky
and see how these trees shade different
buildings
and again since this is done with remote
sensing data it gives us
gives us a way to scale from individual
plants
to landscapes and i have to say having
just lived through
my first austin summer i have a deep
appreciation for the shade these
trees provide but let's get back to
pollen and detroit
so we've now covered plant location and
pollen production
so let's talk about the other process
that we need to predict
pollen emissions which is the timing of
flowering
we know that temperature determines
flowering time and we also know that
urban heat islands and temperature
gradients
in cities are common i therefore
hypothesize that there would also be
differences in flowering time
within detroit to assess the
relationships between temperature
flowering time an airborne pollen i
conducted a field study in detroit
where i measured flowering time for a
bunch of trees in the city
and i measured these flowering phenology
of over 100 trees and nine different
neighborhoods and those neighborhoods
are shown with the hollow symbols
on this map here i then compared
flowering time
with temperature during the early spring
specifically land surface temperature
which comes from
which i and
to get that land surface temperature i
use data from the modis sensor
on the terra and aqua satellites
here are the results for whether
temperature explains flowering
temperature is on the x-axis and the
timing of flowering is on the y-axis
each of these small symbols is a single
tree
and the large symbols are site averages
and as you can see the association is
very strong
and warmer places flower earlier
we can then combine our knowledge of
this relationship
with remote sensing based measurements
of temperature to predict the timing of
flowering across the entire metro area
so next i'm going to show you an
animation of predicted flowering dates
for oak trees in detroit
each of these frames is a day and
flowering is indicated by the yellower
colors
so you can see that wave of flowering
moving from the south
to cooler areas in the north
then by the middle of may you can see
trees
have basically finished flowering
i've now shown you data on the various
processes that determine
um airborne pollen concentrations
including how much pollen is released
where pollen is released from and when
that poem is released
we can then combine all of these
different processes
to predict pollen release over both time
and space
and next i'm going to show you an
animation that puts all of this
together and this
is predicted pollen release for oak
trees in detroit in the spring of 2017.
and here you can see the interplay of
both those spatial features of where oak
trees are
and how much pollen they're releasing as
well as the temporal dynamics
caused by temperature differences across
the city of detroit
now the big question though is whether
this model predicts airborne pollen
at particular times and places
and i'm excited to say that when i
compared
this model of pollen release with
airborne
pollen from the that data set that i
collected with the pollen samplers
this model explained almost half
of the variation in airborne pollen
concentrations for oak trees
i want to emphasize that this is about
nine times better
than simply using pollen measurements
from the nearest pollen monitoring
station as a proxy
which has been the standard practice in
this field at least as it applies to
allergies
allergists have long said that pollen is
everywhere and you can't avoid it
but these results say otherwise there
are real pollen hot spots
and they are also predictable so imagine
having this extra
resolution and accuracy in your pollen
forecast
i think it offers up all sorts of
possibilities
including ways for people to either
avoid pollen hot spots
or to take their medication ahead of
time so it reaches full efficacy
before they're exposed
these types of improvements could
really improve quality of life for many
people
uh but for vulnerable people including
those with
asthma or chronic obstructive pulmonary
disorder
this is a really big deal
you may be wondering about the effect of
wind
and atmospheric dispersion on airborne
pollen concentrations
and i can say it's very big and it
should be included here uh this these
models of pollen release will pair
nicely with atmospheric dispersion
modeling
and i've collected some of the the data
needed to calibrate these models
but i haven't created them yet
i also expect that the same framework
could also be applied to fungal spores
which would have applications
not just an allergy but also in
agricultural
settings so far i've shown you how my
framework works for trees
and in my next example i'm going to turn
towards ragweed which is an early
successional species
that releases vast amounts of allergenic
pollen
and to begin i'd like to acknowledge
tiffany carey who is a mentee of mine
starting in 2010 when we first started a
pollen project together
and i'm really proud of the
contributions that tiffany made
to this work and she's now back in
detroit again
working with the national wildlife
federation on
environmental and social issues there
one of the things that tiffany and i and
i noticed pretty early on
was that there was far more ragweed and
vacant lots in detroit
the city has demolished about 20 000
vacant structures since 2014
and here's a little chrono sequence of
what that looks like so here's
a building that is slated for demolition
and here's the exposed soil
the next spring by the fall
you can see little bits of green in the
lot and that is exactly the habitat
where ragweed thrives
i quantified this habitat across the
city of detroit using remote sensing
data and linked it with
field surveys in order to create a
map of pollen production across the city
of detroit which i'm showing to you here
this approach worked pretty well and i'd
also think that similar methods could be
used for understanding weed populations
across agricultural landscapes
one of our findings was that some
neighborhoods had
lots and lots of ragweed and others had
almost none
the neighborhoods that have many vacant
lots and a lot of ragweed tend to be
poorer
and in fact you can just see the spatial
correlation between
ragweed pollen production and the
percent of detroiters living in poverty
which is shown in this bottom map
the people living in poorer
neighborhoods also tend to have
less access to health care and higher
allergy and asthma rates
so i think this is an example where
ragweed pollen exposure
is actually an environmental justice
issue too
i'd like to take a moment to talk about
this statistic that i've just put on the
screen
that black people in detroit are twice
as likely to be hospitalized for asthma
as white people in detroit now this
isn't the type of statistic that we
usually mention
in plant ecology talks but i think it's
relevant here
because interactions with plants could
be making a certain amount
of contribution to this situation
luckily in this particular case there
are some simple management
recommendations for vacant lots and in
particular it turns out
that you if you either mow regularly the
ragweed goes away
or if you leave the lot on its own
succession happens and ragweed is out
competed
so i've now shown you examples of how
i've quantified the ecological
processes really relating to pollen
release
and how i've scaled this up to the
municipal level for both
oak trees and ragweed but these are just
predictions
in a single city and so the next thing
to do
is to work to scale this up to even
larger
areas and that is what i'm doing as a
postdoc
at the university of texas my research
here
is on cedar fever which is actually
allergies caused by juniper pollen
still this is one of the most important
allergenic pollen producing plants in
the u.s
and part because of how much pollen it
releases
here's a branch of a juniper tree
releasing pollen in january
a really big juniper tree of the species
can release as many as
half a trillion pollen grains each year
anecdotally we know that cedar fever has
big effects on respiratory health in
texas
but that's never been quantified right
now i'm working on an epidemiological
analysis
to compare airborne pollen
concentrations with emergency department
visits for asthma
and the the preliminary results from
this study are showing that cedar fever
is conservatively associated with about
5000 extra emergency department visits
each year
since only the most extreme cases result
in ed visits the true effects of
cedar fever on quality of life for
texans is astronomical
the way i'm going about working on this
problem
is to create similar uh models to what i
did in detroit
and to do so i'm taking the same
approach i'm figuring out how much
pollen individual trees produce
figuring out how where these trees are
and when they release pollen and then
using dispersion modeling
and the goal of this is to create
near-term forecasts
and alerts for cedar fever sufferers in
texas
now to make this work at the state level
i've had to do something different
because i can't drive all around the
state to collect these measurements
myself
so i started a citizen science project
called pollen trackers
through a collaboration with the
national phenology network
volunteers on this project are helping
to collect those measurements upon
release by junipers across texas and we
are just about to go into our second
field season next month
the goal of my work is to develop
process-based models of airborne pollen
at the continental scale models like
this
would fill gaps in our understanding of
both gene flow
and of how much pollen people are
exposed to
forecasts from this model would also be
really useful for people to both reduce
their own exposure
and to better manage their medications
so there are a lot of potential benefits
for having
continental scale models of airborne
pollen and
it would also help us to to do things
like understand the role
of local pollen production versus
long-distance dispersal of pollen
this would have applications not just in
the allergy world but it would also be
really important for understanding gene
flow
of course creating a continental scale
model
is an ambitious goal and
so i've decided to break this up into
several distinct research projects
the first of these projects is
understanding where
trees are and how much pollen they
produce
this is a big task but i think that it's
feasible to do this
the way i propose approaching it is by
combining data
on what trees are where from the forest
inventory and analysis data set
which now uh in addition to including
forested plots it also includes data on
urban trees
this data set of tree locations and
abundance
could be combined with remote sensing
data and in particular
it could be combined with imagery from
satellites like landsat as well as with
lidar from jedi which is
which is another potentially very useful
resource for this project
these estimates of tree abundance could
then be combined with allometric
equations
of pollen production
i have some ideas about how we could do
a better job
of making allometric equations
uh faster and more efficiently
and i think a great place to
parameterize some of those equations
would be are not forest and i think it's
also going to be important here to
include some of the traditional
plant ecology processes that
are also going to affect pollen
production so things like competition
there are a bunch of applications for
these data products
both for pollen but also for
understanding other ecosystem services
and disservices
including things like say the spread of
tree pests and pathogens
across the u.s
i think that nasa would be a good
potential funding source for this
project
specifically through the earth science
research program
in order to create continental scale
models of pollen
we also need to create continental scale
models of flowering time
to create this i propose uh doing a few
things
first expanding my current citizen
science project with the national
phenology network
and they're excited about this
possibility too
we could also get observations of
flowering time from
neon
another possibility is to
to use some new pawn monitoring devices
that i have
been piloting here in texas and these
devices
let me pull one out
these devices allow you to uh it
basically
is a little arduino
motor which can be timed to spin up
a acrylic plate at a certain rate and
these can be placed underneath
trees and you can change the timing of
this so you can get
a very fine resolution estimates of
pollen release
so i right now i'm piloting the idea of
sending these devices out to people in
my pawn trackers program so that they
can both
corroborate the data that they are
collecting because let's be real
citizen science is messy but more
importantly than that
they could augment it by having a finer
temporal understanding of when pollen is
released
these observations of flowering time
could then
be combined with granular climate data
and the combination of these things
could be used to create flowering models
these could then be these flowering
models
could potentially use close to real-time
data
sources in order to create near-term
forecasts
of flowering
better and more accessible models of
flowering time would be useful for
many purposes besides allergies too
and let's see so one example is the risk
of frost damage to flowers
i worked a little bit on this project in
graduate school
and i found and one of the things that
is clear in the literature is that
climate change is increasing the risk of
frost damage to flowers
and in fact in ithaca this year there
was snow on the ground on may 9th
so having a better sense of when
things are flowering could be really
useful for understanding and
responding to frost risk and this i
think would be especially relevant
in orchards this project
would likely be a good fit with nsf and
particularly with the division of
environmental biology
that funded my graduate work
ultimately one of the major
justifications of my research
is to better understand how pollen
affects human health
so that we can do something about that
one of the projects i'm really excited
about
is combining high resolution pollen
exposure data
with high resolution asthma exacerbation
data
the group that's doing this best right
now is a company called propeller health
which uses smart inhalers
that provide information on the time and
location of each asthma inhaler usage
i've discussed combining our data
with them and we think there's a lot of
potential
to use this information both the
fine-grained
pollen exposure estimates with the
fine-grained asthma exacerbation data
to potentially create individualized
dose response curves for people
this also opens up the possibility of
personalized forecasts
and propeller health this company
they already help users to manage their
asthma so there's a clear
avenue for using these estimates
of airborne pollen concentrations
to change how people are managing
allergic diseases including asthma
i think a really good place to work on
this project would be new york city
in part because there are a lot of
people with allergies there and a lot of
good sources
of uh data that i would need to create
models of airborne pollen there
but also because i think there's a lot
of potential to
collaborate with physicians at while
cornell medicine
having these types of personalized
forecasts and don'ts
and dose response curves would be a
game-changing project from an allergies
perspective
and i think this would be very
competitive for funding from the
national institute of
environmental health sciences
these research topics that i've been
talking about
there's a multitude of little projects
within them
that would be excellent projects for
graduate and undergraduate students
i look forward to working with students
on this research in the future
and i also think that some of these
topics
could apply well to both existing
classes at sips
and to new potential classes too such as
a
class on the links between plants and
human health
and since chris mentioned it this photo
here is actually from the the class as
she mentioned
this new intro to ecology field class
that had about a hundred master's
students in it in that class we used
active and inquiry-based pedagogy and
those are approaches that i hope to use
and
teaching in the future as well
10 my talk i have two conclusions first
that process-based approaches offer an
effective framework
for modeling airborne pollen my second
conclusion
is that the combination of these
research themes
are a very useful toolkit and today i've
told you about how i've applied them in
a few ways in my own study system
but i'm also excited to see how my
methods could be used to
answer questions in other systems
including farms and orchards
so over the next couple of days i'm
really excited to chat with you all
about ideas like this and also about the
potential for
collaboration in the future so with that
i'd like to acknowledge these
institutions for their financial support
and i'd also like to thank some of the
many people who contributed to this
research
both at the university of michigan and
now at the university of texas at austin
so with that i would be happy to take
your questions
thank you all right thank you dan
really appreciated that uh
are there questions for dan
you're welcome to unmute
or put them in the chat or i'm trying to
open up all my windows here
uh raise your hand we have so many
options
nina do you have a question yeah hi dan
uh how you doing thanks for the
presentation um
i just wondered about you know obviously
pollen does
cause allergies and cause reactions but
uh
you know is there a possibility of
looking at this and
as a control group in a forested area as
opposed to an
urban tree area i would imagine to be
more trees in a more forested area than
one
in an urban area and i just wondered if
you looked at
sort of a control group of trees
yeah i think that's a really interesting
point
um i think there's a couple of
reasons why i've focused in on urban
trees
specifically that we interact the most
with the trees
that are closest to us and those
and there's also so there's so the the
incremental effect of an individual tree
in a city
is much stronger on health than that of
a tree in a forest
i think there are a bunch of really cool
questions that we can answer using these
same approaches for
um for more rural forests too though and
i think
there though one of the more interesting
sets of questions is about gene flow
but i think the same approaches could
could be used for that
um when it comes to allergies there's
also the
there's this thing where people who live
in rural areas
also tend to develop fewer allergies
compared to people living in cities
uh so that is another reason to focus
more on
actually that's a another issue that
there are other aspects of urban life
that cause allergies than
pollen you know basically automobile
exhausts hydrocarbons i mean
that's a big factor and that's not
really factored in with your model
and i wondered if you had some
response to that yeah certainly that's a
great question
and so it's not factored into my model
of pollen exposure
but it is factored into epidemiological
analyses
and so that's where we need to do things
like uh
figure out uh the effect of various air
pollutants including particulate matter
for example and ozone which interacts a
little bit with pollen
uh and that's also where we need to
do things like understand the effects of
say viruses on emergency department
visits just
to reference the epidemiological
analysis that i'm doing now
so all of those things are important and
will affect uh the proportion of
some health outcome that is attributable
to pollen specifically because
trees also uh reduce
particulates in areas i mean they do
uh particulates to land on leaves and uh
are so the particulates in the air tend
to be less
where there are trees so there's a lot
of different
competing issues here and it's i wonder
if
pollen alone is the major issue in terms
of asthma
yeah i appreciate the pushback here and
i think it's
what you're making are very good points
and
however just because there are other
issues doesn't mean we shouldn't
understand
allergenic pollen and moreover these
same approaches are really
useful for doing things like
understanding how
much particulate matter these trees can
filter out
so i think that these are great points
and i'd
i'd be happy to go through it more with
you because i think
pollen is just one issue and ultimately
we need to weigh
both the ecosystem services and the
ecosystem disservices that these trees
are providing
and that is ultimately what should
govern our decisions about tree
selection
josh you had your hand raised
yeah thanks sir great talk dan so
in the beginning of your presentation
you mentioned that um
i think you said poland was becoming
more allergenic
do you mean on a per pollen grain basis
or contextually in the context of other
environmental components
well i'm afraid it's both unfortunately
uh yeah so i we have some good
lab experiments that show that plants
grown and higher
carbon dioxide concentrations produce
pollen grains that are on a per pollen
grain unit
more allergenic and so
a lot of that work has been done on
ragweed and
yeah it's so yeah it's on a per
pond grain basis so to kind of continue
that
line of thought i guess many many
secreted
cell wall proteins in pollen are
allergens and
is anybody looking at that looking at
the the allergenic profiles of syllable
protein
clusters yeah i think there's a little
bit of work being done on that
um i would have to to look in my uh
my literature folder and see exactly
what
is being done there um it's it's
certainly something which is
of interest to a lot of people um
and yeah so i'll look a little bit more
at my papers
and and then give you a better answer in
our one-on-one meeting
you'll be too lazy thanks there's a
question in chat on pollen morphology
yeah that was me um yeah i really liked
your your talk and i really want to say
that i like the use of arduino
uh to measure pollen released i think
that's really cool
um but i had a question about whether or
not you're incorporating pollen
morphology
to inform like your flowering models and
the only reason i asked is because i'm
not 100
sure about pollen grains and oak
across oak species i would i would go
out on a limb here and
like ask you do you know like they have
like different
morphologies across um species of oak
and maybe if that's something
that can affect like whether or not
they're allergenic
yeah oh that's an excellent question and
so i have a couple of responses first of
all
uh oak pollen grains generally look
fairly similar and so the standard
practice
in the field of um aerobiology
is not it's not to even try and
identify what pollen grain comes from
red oak versus from white oak or
something like that because you can't do
it reliably
that being said there are
differences in say the allergenicity
of different closely related species
and so even if it's not something that
we can just see
morphologically just
using a microscope it can have important
consequences for allergies
does that answer your question
so when you it kind of gets at it like
when you mean like
um i guess characteristics of
allergenicity are you referring to like
the shape
of like the pollen grain i'm referring
more to what's inside the pollen grain
and a lot of them and so there are a
variety
of proteins inside of pollen grains and
substances which
trigger allergic reactions and and so
those can vary a little bit
it is easier to quantify the variation
in the the cellular content and
specifically
and the the allergic reactions that uh
the contents of a pollen grain
produce than it is to say that hey like
there's a
slightly like thicker exon on this
pollen grain than that one
something like that so it's more about
the the
the protein composition than it is about
the shape
um however shape can be important for
things like
um how easy how easily a pollen grain
bursts and releases all of that stuff
into the air which is a really
uh important part of this whole story
that i haven't had a chance to talk
about today
yeah i was just kind of thinking about
um if like for instance like the x sign
is
thicker on one pollen grain uh versus
like
the rest of the lot then it would
potentially disperse
differently
yeah entirely um and that i think
is something that we'll need to do a
little bit more of taking into account
when it comes to dispersion modeling
and things like the amount of water that
a pollen grain picks up
is pretty important there oh yeah so
that's a
great point cool thanks i really enjoyed
your talk
thank you there are a bunch of questions
here um from a plant but fellow plant
pathologist
uh interactions between pollen and
fungal spores
as many fungal spores are also
allergenic
do your marks take into account yeah
yeah totally and i think so
you may have been a little surprised by
how little we know
about airborne pollen you would be even
more surprised by how little
the allergy community knows about uh
airborne fungal spores
they are smaller they're much harder to
identify
just with a microscope and so we know a
lot less
about that that being said i i think
that there might be some possibilities
for
using the framework that i've done here
like figuring out
source strength and the number of
particulates released i think there
might be some potential to do that with
fungal spores too um
and i should also mention that yeah
fungal spores
are really important to allergies too um
they generally
are there's a few national allergy
bureau stations that measure them that
measure fungal spores
but it's not as common to include that
in this type of analysis
and david rossiter asks if you notice
differential wind effects in the detroit
study
he noticed cooler temperatures just
inland from
lake saint claire and could that be a
wind effect
yeah yeah i've wondered a lot about uh
the effects of wind there myself um
i i think that it's likely that
some of the the distance from water is
affecting things
like temperature um but that being said
um if if things like wind
are something of uh
can are adding extra
variation once we include that
in our models then these models are just
going to improve
and so i think that's an area which i
would
love to to add more in on because it's
just going to
allow me to make better predictions of
airborne pollen once we do things like
incorporate variation in wind across the
city
as well as you know like which direction
the wind is blowing and how strong and
that all that stuff too and somewhat
related chelsea
asks uh uh can you use your methods to
track pollen
for plants that are not wind pollinated
oh yeah it's a really fun uh question
so right now my co-advisor is shaolin
who and all of her work is on
insect pollinated plants and so i think
one of the really
cool topics here is could we
use some of these same methods to figure
out um
the amount of pollen production across
like an agricultural landscape or a wild
landscape and actually
a buddy of mine from grad school aaron
iverson who
just has been at cornell for the last
few years and now
got a faculty position elsewhere we've
been bouncing around the idea of
using uh some of these same
methods to to get a sense of what the
foraging landscape would be like for a
pollinator
so lots of cool possibilities for that
there's one other question uh which
again
as a plant pathologist and someone who i
have a project on rust fungi
so the spores of rust fungi can be can
be highly ornamented
and the question is actually um uh can
can your models be applied to uh rust
pathogen spores because uh
several people online today are allergic
to rust pathogen spores
and i think to some extent you already
spoke to that but they are
uh the arena spores tend to be um
wildly wind windblown totally well
hey i say let's give it a shot let's see
what happens
and uh one of our um uh
hemp students says i can't wait to see
this type of
modeling applied to pollen and pathogens
in the hemp industry
any uh any final questions for uh dan
before we let him go off to his next
meetings
chelsea i just had a quick one and it
kind of goes back to your
detroit study so i apologize if i'm
getting some of the information wrong
but i was thinking about
you were mentioning that that there's a
preponderance of cases where there's an
increase in the
in the in certain communities
for being hospitalized for asthma in
particular areas that are also
associated with having greater densities
of ragweed
did i get that right yeah there's a
correlation there
um the the causal links are a little
more tenuous and i'm not going to say
that and i cannot
in any way say that it is ragweed that
completely causes that but
there could be a fraction of that which
ragweed contributes to
so is there i was thinking about that
from like the public health i mean is
this a
a place where the medical
practitioners could go in and say hey
look this is an area that
doesn't have a lot of asthma knowledge
because i can imagine also certain
communities just aren't even exposed to
the healthcare system that would provide
them with
understanding of how asthma can be
both provoked and prevented in in
children
um so just thinking that this could be a
way that the collaboration with the
medical community say hey listen
these are areas that are potentially
high risk these are communities where
you could go
and and do some public health
educational services
or offer clinics or things like that
yeah i think that is one of the the most
important potential
applications of this work and my other
co-advisor here is an allergist
elizabeth matsui
and her claim to fame is doing studies
in baltimore that looked at
how differences in pest control
specifically
with mice affected people's risk of
developing
asthma um and so um
i'm a plant scientist but i think uh
there's a lot of room here for these
approaches to be used for public health
interventions
and and that's why i'm currently
as a plant scientist based out of a
medical school here
so i completely agree thank you for the
the softball question i love it
and uh bill bill corpay notes
uh that the methods could be used in uh
forensic botany
and as an aside bill teaches a class
oddly in forensic botany yeah
um completely there's actually this
really interesting project that's being
done largely at
ut austin now that's funded through the
murray mechanism
this is the department of defense and
they have this like
god it's it's this massively funded
project um to use some of this to
to use pollen as a tracker for figuring
out
where things have been um
so yeah totally super useful for all of
that as well
and carlin has a question but she's
going to ask it tomorrow because if i
don't stop this
people will riot it's been great sorry
carlin i love you
it's it's been really fun uh talking
with you today dan and i hope you enjoy
your conversations with folks across the
school of integrative plant science so
everyone please
joining join me in thanking dan for a
great seminar
thank you and i'll look forward to
chatting with you all over the next few
days
looking forward to it cheers
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu